-Bizarrap. Do I call you Bizarrap or Biza?
Or -- What do I call you? -It's fine.
Biza, for you, is okay.
-[ Laughs ] For me, it's okay. Yeah.
And I'm going to call you Shakira, obviously.
Welcome back. -"Shak."
-I can call you Shak, as well, yeah, of course.
Congratulations. "Music Sessions, Volume 53."
This is a global monster of a song.
Number one globally!
[ Cheers and applause ] Number one globally.
Couldn't -- I mean, couldn't be a bigger song.
This is the truth. This happened today.
You and Biza,
here are four Guinness World Records you shattered.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then -- And then you went on -- Shakira --
went on and won 10 more Guinness World Records.
I'm not kidding. Look at this. Look at this!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at all -- Look at you guys.
Most viewed -- Most viewed Latin track on YouTube in 24 hours.
Fastest Latin track to reach 100 million views on YouTube.
Most streamed Latin track on Spotify in 24 hours.
Most streamed Latin track on Spotify in one week.
You crushed it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You crushed it!
Uh, how did this song come together?
Did you know Biza? Did you know Shakira?
-Well, you know, my son, Milan, who just turned 10.
-I love --
By the way, they're so excited to be here.
They're like -- I told them, "Guess what.
We're going to New York." And they said,
"Are we going to Fallon?!" I said, "Yeah."
And they started, "Fallon! Fallon! Fallon!"
-That's my boy. I love those two.
They're the cutest, and they're the most polite kids.
I love them. Every time I see them,
they're so nice. So they hooked you up?
-Okay, yeah, so -- Yeah, well, actually, you know,
they're like my career consultants lately.
-Yeah, of course. -They pitch in for video ideas.
I listen to everything they say
because they actually have really good taste.
But I'm not objective, you know? -Yeah, of course not.
-And Milan -- he's also a musician.
He has a very good ear, very good taste.
And he's a big Biza fan.
And he told me, "Mom..."
Like, a few months ago, he told me,
"Mom, you've got to collaborate with Bizarrap.
You have to get on a song with Bizarrap
because you guys are gonna be number one."
And he sent a voice note to my manager, Jaime.
He said, "Jaime, you got to put my mom together with Bizarrap
on a song because they're gonna be number one."
And he was right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He called it. I love that he called it.
-I still have that audio.
-You have the voicemail. -Yeah.
-What's your version of this story, Biza?
-I was thinking about the collaboration
between Shakira and me, but I didn't know
how to reach her because she's --
-She's Shakira. -She's a superstar.
-You have to put a light up in the sky
and hope that Shakira swings in.
She's a superhero. Yeah.
-By that time, I think it was July of the past year, 2022.
And I had, at that moment --
I had the number-one global song with Quevedo.
He's a guy from Spain.
-I love that song. It's amazing.
-And I thought, like, this is a moment to send her a DM.
-To introduce yourself to Shakira.
-Yeah. -He DM'd me.
-You slid into her DMs? -Yeah.
-Yeah, but I didn't see his until, like, three months later.
I don't know why. -Yeah, one or two months later.
-Yeah, two months later.
-And I remember it was --
-You made him wait two months?
-Yeah, but it wasn't on purpose.
-Yeah, we don't answer every DM back.
-Yeah, of course. -She's Shakira. Yeah.
-And it was August, I remember because it was my birthday,
and I -- We were in the studio.
-It was your birthday? -Yeah, I remember that.
I started my -- We were in the studio,
and I started my birthday with Shakira
singing me the "Happy Birthday."
-Ohh! -Do you remember that?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. -How cool.
-Yeah, yeah. That was -- -But what do you --
What's your pitch when you're DMing Shakira?
Like, "Let's do a song together. Let's collaborate."
-Yeah. I told her, like,
"I would really like to collab with you."
And I had that -- that big song out there.
-Yeah, and you were like, "That's me."
-Yeah. "That's me."
-That was very easy, actually.
-Yeah, but you made him wait two months
before even answering back.
-But after I heard that he actually DM'd me,
then I wrote him back.
And, you know, I showed Milan.
I said, "Look who's writing to Mommy!"
And he said, "Oh, my God! The Argentinian God!"
-Oh, really? -Yeah.
-The Argentinian God? -The Argentinian God.
-And, Biza, when you have those, did you think of a beat
immediately and you go like, "This is the one for Shakira"?
And then how do you just go -- You don't just say yes to it.
Do you go, "Hey, I got some notes,"
or, "I'm don't know if I'm feeling this"?
-Well, he came to Barcelona, right?
-Yeah, I came to Barcelona.
And one day before, I made like two beats, I think.
And then when I show the two beats to her,
she told me like, "This is the..."
-Yeah, because it reminded me kind of like --
It reminded me of Depeche Mode a little bit.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. -Right?
-Depeche Mode? -Yeah. Yeah.
This song, if you listen to it, it's got a little bit of that
sort of, like, cool, dark undertone.
I love Depeche Mode. It's my favorite.
-Yeah, it has a lot of synths,
and it sounds like an '80s track, maybe.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And, yeah, I really love that kind of music.
And I knew that Shakira would love that.
-I started to feel it in my body, you know.
I usually have this visceral
sort of physical reaction to music.
And if you see me, you know, two-stepping,
things are not right.
You know? Yeah.
I know when a song works because then I suddenly start moving,
like, getting these small contractions
from my tailbone to my iliac bone,
and then it just results into, you know, hip movements.
-Are you telling me that your hips don't lie?
-Yeah. I didn't want to go there.
-This is the best thing that ever happened to me!
This is the greatest! I can retire now.
This is all I ever wanted to know,
is if, really, if your hips do lie or don't lie to you.
You're actually telling us --
-They do not lie. -They do not lie.
-They do not ever. -You can feel it.
-And I know when a song is right when they start to move.
-Wow! You know what's great about this?
People from all over the world love this song,
but also all ages love this song.
And I have a video here of some fans singing along to the song.
Let's just take a look at this for a second.
-[ Singing in Spanish ]
♪♪
-[ Laughs ] -I mean...
-Do you love that? That's got to make you feel good, right?
-Oh, my God. Yeah, it's been amazing.
I'm just waiting for someone to just pinch me
and wake me up from this dream.
It's unbelievable to feel the reaction from so many people.
I think that people really connect to music
when it's really genuine, when it's real,
when it comes from a real place. -Yeah.
-And the thing with the song is that it has become sort of
like an anthem for so many women out there.
You know, I've had a very rough year after my separation.
And writing this song has been so important to me.
It's been a healthy way to channel my emotions.
And I feel that, you know, after we put out this song,
I really felt that I don't even have fans out there.
I have a sisterhood of women
who have been through the same things
that I have been through, who think the way I think,
who feel the way I feel,
who had to put up with so much crap the way I had to.
And, you know, I did write the song for me,
but, also, I feel that it was meant to be --
and probably for so many women out there
that needed a forum, too, and a voice to represent them
in so many ways, so...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We can't wait to see you perform for us after the break.
Congrats, again, on all the records broken.
Bizarrap! Shakira!
"Music Sessions, Volume 53" is out now!